J'ai dû changer de numéro de téléphone,
parce que quelqu'un l'avait posté sur un forum, alors du coup mon téléphone n'arrêtait pas de sonner.
Et mon répondeur était plein de messages...
intéressants.
Allô, Cyprien... alors tu fais caca... tu fais caca parce que j'ai ton numéro de téléphone.
Les mecs, vous êtes des génies. Oh oui!
Ben ouais, je suis déçu, ça faisait presque dix ans que j'avais mon numéro de téléphone.
Je me rappelle je l'avais eu avec Universal Music Mobile.
La pub: Salut, c'est Chico, tu veux téléphoner pas cher,
toi aussi va chercher bonheur chez ton marchand de journaux, va, va, va.
Je crois qu'à l'époque la drogue c'était super courant en fait, hein.
Chico, va chercher bonheur.
Alors heureusement que mon nouveau numéro c'est pas un 07, hein.
Un 07, vous imaginez, comme les enfants quoi.
Je préfère encore me...
*clic*
*BANG!*
Alors du coup je me suis souvenu du téléphone portable que j'avais à l'époque.
Mon tout premier téléphone portable.
Le Ericsson T10.
Non, c'est... Non, pas Sony Ericsson, à l'époque c'était juste Ericsson.
Regardez-le bien parce qu'il m'a fallu trois semaines pour le trouver.
En fait, le truc qui m'a le plus marqué avec ce téléphone,
à part le fait qu'il soit tellement lourd, que quand je le mettais dans ma poche, je boitais,
c'est surtout qu'il PEUT envoyer des SMS,
mais uniquement en majuscules.
Spécialité...
Ce qui fait que mes potes me prenaient un petit peu pour un fou.
*crie*
Oui, parce que j'étais le seul à avoir un T10, hein.
Tous les autres jeunes de la planète avaient le 3310, et oui.
Il avait deux choses en plus des autres téléphones, il avait des jeux comme... le snake...
Vous voulez rejouer à Snake,
alors cliquez sur pause, appuyez sur la flèche de gauche pendant quelques instants, puis sur la flèche du haut.
C'était l'astuce de Cyprien.
Il avait des jeux comme le snake.
Et il avait un compositeur de sonneries.
Ce qui fait que les gens se prenaient un petit peu pour des mélomanes.
Hé, Cyprien.
*sonnerie du téléphone*
Le générique des Simpsons, à l'oreille.
Après ça il y eu la surenchère à la technologie dans les téléphones portables.
Genre, les premiers téléphones avec appareil photo,
qui avaient une résolution totalement moisie.
Ah ouais, il est mignon ton chien.
C'est une photo de ma mère.
Ça l’empêche pas d'être mignonne.
T'as une jolie maman, quoi, c'est bien.
D'ailleurs le truc qu'on a oublié, c'est qu'à l'époque la batterie des téléphones portables tenait une semaine.
Une semaine.
C'est à dire que vous pouvez le recharger tous les jeudis..., par exemple.
Le truc impensable aujourd'hui, hein, d'ailleurs la question la plus demandée dans le monde,
après "Quand est-ce qu'on mange?", c'est:
*chant* Alléluia!
Le Saint Graal.
Parce que la batterie d'un iPhone, ça tient quoi... 24 heures... super idée.
Et parce qu'aujourd'hui, tout le monde, mais tout le monde a un iPhone.
Ça je m'en rends compte quand je vais en soirée chez des potes.
Cyprien, tu me passes mon téléphone s'il te plait?
Ouais, bien sûr.
Ouais, c'est le téléphone noir là, juste là.
Oui, je sais, je sais.
N'hésitez pas à partager ma vidéo sur Facebook et rejoignez ma page.
Non, là tu refroidis... non c'est pas celui là, c'est vraiment le noir là.
Et retrouvez toutes mes autres vidéos sur cyprien.fr .
Non non, c'est pas celui-là, non non c'est l'autre, le téléphone, le noir.
Sous-titres: Warteks
*Répondeur* Vendredi à 23h02
*Message vocal* Allô, Cyprien, alors tu fais caca,
tu fais caca parce que j'ai ton numéro de téléphone.
Alors pourquoi tu décroches pas, Cyprien?
Pourquoi tu décroches pas ton téléphone?